what's going on guys and welcome to Free
pilot training today I'm going to show
you how to fly a VFR cross country using
just an old-fashioned VFR NAD log and
just a simple VFR chart I got my
father-in-law Mike with me today and um
well he's about to do a quick run up for
me I want to talk about a couple things
we need to do before we take on
first the first thing we need to do is
obviously if you want to pick up a VFR
Flight Plan you need to go ahead and
file that and I already did that right
before we left here
another thing is that we need to write
down or take off time
I'm expecting to take off about 7 20 but
we'll see what that actual time is here
in just a second and the last thing we
need to remember to do is to hack the
clock
I'm going to be using this clock on the
transponder today for all the timing
calculations uh it's easy for both of us
to reach so this is a good one you can
always use a watch if you need to but
this is what I'm going to be using is
the transponder when you do those three
things before we take off otherwise our
calculations are going to be out to
lunch one more thing I want to talk
about before we take off is navigating
to your first Waypoint
not many instructors explain this but
it's really important so we can start
across country at the correct spot
unless you're super lucky and your
Runway heading is aligned with your
course you're going to need a way to get
to your first Waypoint one way you can
get to your first Waypoint is by using
pilotage this just means that we find
big landmarks and use those as a
reference to find our first Waypoint for
example I know that my first Waypoint is
going to be to the right of this giant
lake so if I keep myself right at this
Lake I should be able to find it
another way is to assume that you're
going to fly Runway heading for a couple
of miles then come up with a wind
corrected heading to your first Waypoint
and you'll do this the same way you
calculated the heading for the rest of
your legs if you notice on my VFR nav
log I did this for both North and South
float today just in case the winds look
better for a North departure all right I
think we're about ready to go I'm gonna
go ahead and put this in the GPS just to
back ourselves up
all right we're going to kilo bisky Lima
Delta
all right direct enter enter
and I'll put the NAB up here
we'll talk about this a little bit more
here in just a minute
ready yes
okay
all right my controls clock's still
running I got seat belts on fuel
selector valve on both
trim set for takeoff uh let's see makes
your best power car beats off throttle
set for now everything's good over there
we got the lights on
uh we'll go I'll go ahead and go landing
and taxi lights on for the takeoff clear
right yeah we're going to be departing
to the South if you don't mind shutting
your window go get this puppy rolling do
you want to take off I'm gonna drive two
miles and then I'm Gonna Make a Right
turnout
um to looks like 278 on the heading
all right finals clear we're ready for
takeoff
ebony to traffic Skyhawk 3148 x-ray
departing one seven departing to the
Northwest Bonita
all right power's coming in got oil
pressure
air speeds coming alive
we are ready to go and right about here
I just made a huge mistake I forgot to
start the timer and while it's pretty
embarrassing for me I'm gonna go ahead
and make the video with this footage
because I think you guys are going to
learn a lot more from my mistakes and
see how to fix the problem if you were
to do the same thing
five knots there's our rotation speed
we've got some birds just above us but
there should be no Factor I'm gonna turn
this puppy out we were safely Airborne
landing and taxi lights coming off Flats
already up I can take out checklist is
complete uh we're gonna drive it out two
miles and then we're gonna make our
right turn to
uh 278 and like I said this is a heading
I came up with based on my win so
I got these wins 12 hours in advance so
they might be slightly off but uh we'll
see I guess I'm gonna try to get ahead
of the airplane here I'm gonna go ahead
and load in 28.6 because that's going to
be Kansas City Center
and where you are listening
we're climbing up to 4 500 that's a good
Westerly heading uh we're using Sweden
today
um there's about two miles we'll go
ahead and make a right hand turn out to
2 78 climbing out of 70 knots this is
going to keep us on track to hit our top
of climb at the correct time expecting
to hit her top of climb at looks like 10
minutes to 20 seconds
Center 135.45
coming out at 70. and I'm just going to
trim her up so she does all the work for
me
and I forgot to hack
or say we're a minute behind right now
at this point a minute behind is a
complete guess but once I hit my top of
climb I'm gonna be able to make a lot
more accurate estimation and I'll show
you how I came up with those numbers but
also I'm going to show you another way
you can solve the problem if you don't
want to try to make estimations in
flight so I'm going to say I'm a minute
behind and then take off time was 7 18.
as long as your estimated takeoff time
is within five minutes of your actual
takeoff time this is going to be good
enough because all you're going to be
using this for is to let the flight
service station know what time you took
off this is going to allow them to
update your estimated time of arrival
but for your navigation calculations you
want those times to be within a minute
if you can make sure we're applying our
heading climbing out of 70 knots all
right let me make a departure call here
animated traffic Skyhawk free one four
eight x-ray departing your airspace to
the Southwest or Northwest Bonita
foreign
Kansas City Center actually I might try
to go ahead and get on with uh
McAllister radio uh we'll try to pick up
that flight plan
I'm the
4500 we're at 2 500 climbing right now
we got a good heading
I'll go ahead and try to pick that up
real quick looks like 22-5
Conquest uh foreign
[Applause]
diameter McAllister radio McAllister
radio Skyhawk 3148 x-ray transmitting
and receiving on 22-5
we're trying to get these guys in the
past and uh
it's it's kind of Hit or Miss up here
I should be within range of this flight
service station and at a good altitude
so I'm not sure why I'm not picking
these guys up I'll try again here in
just a second all right 3 000 climbing 4
500. now the winds I I got the wins last
night uh you know 12 hours in advance
and it looks like they're slightly wrong
so
actually as we're getting higher it
looks like we're getting closer to what
we need so this might actually work out
I'm gonna try the I'll try the polite
service station one more time
McAllister radio McAllister radio
Skyhawk 3148 x-ray transmitting and
receiving on 22.5
now we're up
[Applause]
if we don't get them that's fine since
these guys didn't answer today I do have
a video specifically on how to open up a
VFR flight plan so be sure to check that
out if you need it back over to my
all right so I'm not picking them up so
we're gonna go ahead we're gonna go
ahead and go to Kansas City Center and
we'll pick a fight following for the
trip here I think 422 Kansas City Center
good morning climbing Tampa three seven
zero
three seven zero FedEx 422 34 22
reaching 1 1000 for the director igloo
reaching one one thousand direct Igloo
for FedEx 422. Kansas City Center
Skyhawk 3148 x-ray three one four to
x-ray Kansas City Center Roger all right
go ahead uh yes sir three one four eight
x-ray we're about five nautical miles to
the northwest of Bonita that's Hotel
zero four three thousand five hundred
climbing four thousand five hundred I
like dfr flight following to Whiskey
Lima Delta that's Strother field number
three one four eight x-rays clock two
one four three
[Applause]
come come back and give us like a
altimeter setting here in just a second
[Applause]
we'll see what they give us all right so
things I'm thinking about tractor 140x
tray rate of contact 35 miles Northeast
of the Tulsa VOR sale
three one four eight x-ray report extra
Roger the independence
okay so sorry about that uh things I'm
thinking about we're still climbing up
to our altitude
we want to write these times down as we
as we hit them but so I've got some
acronyms so for each Waypoint that we
hit I want you to remember t-hat or Top
Hat the first thing is time so when you
hit a waypoint or your top of climb
write down your time and then you're
heading sometimes you need to change
your heading in this example after I hit
my top of climb I need to change my
heading from 278 to 282
as you can see here the change is really
minimal but you might have to make big
changes if you're trying to avoid air
space or something okay and then a is
altitude
[Applause]
um you may need to change altitude
sometimes so that's just something to
think about uh and then the last thing
is your turn Point what's the next turn
point we're looking for uh for us today
our next turnpoint is going to be an
airport off our left hand side that's
going to be kind of quite 401K location
head back here
you got 100 feet to level off
okay so we're at our top of climb I got
uh seven minutes and 30 seconds on that
one now normally you just write that
time down right here but as you may
remember I messed up and didn't start my
timing until a little bit late so one
way to fix your timing problem is to
assume that your top of climb is pretty
close to being accurate I was supposed
to hit my top of climb at 10 minutes and
20 seconds but according to my timer I
hit it at 7 minutes and 30 seconds so to
make things easy on myself I'm gonna say
I hit my top of climb at 10 minutes and
30 seconds because this is going to
allow my timer to read exactly three
minutes shy of what we actually are now
if you're not very good at making top of
climb calculations you might not want to
use this method and to be honest you
don't even really need to fill in the
top of climb timing information anyways
there's really not very many time Fuel
and distance calculations you can make
until you get to your first Waypoint so
now you're going to hear me correct
myself and tell you that we're closer to
being three minutes off on our timing
then for the rest of the flight we can
simply add three minutes to whatever we
see on the top timer actually we're
probably flying closer to three minutes
I'm gonna go ahead and write that down
three minutes not one minute uh before I
started the timer so I I skipped three
minutes so looks like uh 10 minutes and
30 seconds 25 63 Kansas City
and after I went back and reviewed the
video footage I actually started the
timer exactly two minutes and 24 seconds
late so my timing is about 36 seconds
off at this point just in case you were
wondering the other method is to Simply
restart your clock every time you fly
over a waypoint and this is by far the
easiest way to do it because we know
exactly how long each leg should take
because we calculated those in these
spots right here so in this example I
need to restart my clock as soon as I
hit my top of climb and you can remember
to do that by using the top hat acronym
that we talked about earlier but the bad
thing about this method is that you have
to remember to restart your clock every
time you fly over a waypoint that's why
I like to write my total time over here
that way I only have to remember to hack
the clock one time because as you can
see it's pretty easy to forget to do
that so once we hit level up we want to
do our cruise checklist let's go knock
that out first of all
173.50 three minutes or less and then
the cruise checklist is going to be
sent proper RPM settings so I chose 2400
today as you can see on my
um ad log and that's going to allow us
to determine exactly how much fuel we're
burning per hour and it also helps us
determine what our true air speed should
be and that's the Baseline for all our
calculations uh then we're going to go
ahead and lean out the mixture here
okay and now we're ready to go uh you
will find some other things in other
cruise checklists but uh that's all
there is on this airplane a little off
altitude there yeah we got a good
headwind yeah yeah slow we're going to
the left all right so our next Waypoint
is going to be an airport off the
left-hand side making sure that we're
aviating are we flying the airplane are
we Wings level right now navigating or
watching off of Kansas City
by these wins I'm getting back to course
here now I can hear that the engine's
revving up so I'm going to go ahead and
re-pull that back all right it's like
arrival Kansas City Center
maintain 5 000 Stillwater altimeter okay
now that we're on our way to our first
Waypoint I want to give you a memory aid
that's going to make you an expert at
these cross countries I want you to
remember clock to map to ground I don't
want you just looking for your Waypoint
before you get there I want you to wait
until the clock says that you're getting
close and what this does is it keeps you
from biting off on a landmark that's not
actually your Waypoint here's an example
of how that could happen let's say
you're flying this cross country here
and one of your waypoints is this Road
next to Owensville if I'm just flying
along looking for waypoints and I'm not
paying attention I could easily fly over
this road right here next to Lonsdale
and think I've reached my Waypoint but
in reality it's still quite a ways in
front of us but by using the clock to
map to ground method if I wait till I'm
about a minute out for my Waypoint then
I'm way less likely to bite off on a
wrong Waypoint like this one so if I
take a look at my nav log I should start
looking for the Nowata airport off my
left wing somewhere around 18 minutes
and 1 seconds of total time or 7 minutes
and 41 seconds from my last Waypoint and
for this leg that was my top of climb
yep so 18 minutes and one second
we'll start looking at her map and then
look outside
okay another thing I could think about
is I did calculate a indicated air speed
for this trip and uh
you're not if you don't have the proper
power setting set and make sure that you
get that and it can change as you're
moving so it doesn't hurt to
periodically yeah
indicated so if I'm not seeing that then
I know it's going to take me a little
bit longer
get to our destination we are still
speeding up because uh we just leveled
off a few minutes ago
um
contact Kansas City Center 132.25
Delta 24 28 that was for another
aircraft I got your check on a flight of
a three seven zero and you are still
directed probably a little bit busier on
the radios today because we're actually
going to an air show in uh Wichita uh
but we're not going to go all the way up
to Wichita we're going up to
strotherfield which is just south of
Wichita and then we're gonna get picked
up by
picked up by the family might not be the
funnest video to make uh going into the
air show I don't even know if you can
land on McConnell or not right now
Brickyard 45 35 contact Kansas City
Center one three three point four seven
you're born
all right so our first time
I remember
we're looking for is 1801 I started my
time three minutes late thank you so
uh should be at 1501 where we start
looking outside and seeing our airport
and I put a little L next to it so
that's that means that it's off our left
wing it's good to pick waypoints that
are either to the left or to the right
because that way you can get your timing
closer to being accurate if you pick
something directly underneath you it's
going to be difficult to tell that
you're directly above all right let's
hear the cinnamon ten three thousand one
hundred so we are flying 82 knots right
now as expecting 96. so I'm actually
expecting to be slightly slow
uh but we'll see where's that fly
computer look in the side pocket there's
somewhere stuck in that uh folder or
made somewhere in there
got it your controls
should have checked that before we left
and this raises a good point what if you
forget to bring or can't find your
flight computer on your cross country
should we just roll invert it in pool or
should we use something else to come up
with our calculations don't worry I'm
not going to roll inverted on you here
of course
there
[Applause]
oh well I'll use the 60 to 1 rule if we
have to all right my controls center all
the way 3590 is uh one four thousand
climbing one five thousand but don't
worry I'll go ahead and solve a couple
of these with the flight computer as
well
all right clock or Adder time
so look down at the map
what do we see we see our airport off
the left-hand side now we start looking
outside do we see our Airport
no we do not we are we're not up here no
we're not quite there yet yeah so we're
looking for no water I know where it is
because I'm familiar with this area Mike
knows as well uh so it's actually Dead
Ahead probably about 10 miles or so so
we are behind we expect to be behind but
actually now that my ending now that I
say that my indicated air speeds up
where it should be but it's his headwind
that's lowering our ground speed and
it's causing us to be behind we weren't
quite expecting this big of a headwind
today so as you can see it's really
advantageous to wait to the last
possible minute to throw in your wins
for cross-country planning so we're
going to be behind but we will see
zero
FedEx 422 leaving 330 for 370. did you
see it yeah I got it okay oh wait till
it's off our wing to get a good hack uh
but he's seeing it out there
I think the winds might be just a little
bit stronger yeah
three minutes behind on my timing we
should get there 1801
so we should have got there at 1501.
and you're going to find yourself uh
trying to correct your heading like
multiple times throughout the fight it's
it's going to be a constant struggle
especially if you're dealing with some
kind of crosswind the whole time so your
prerogative the serious traffic's now
about uh Wonder miles east of the field
looks like they're in a left base
include Bridge Approach uh Stewart
Airport
now you select cancel you want to hang
on to the iPhone until you're on the
ground
for a rubber eye for cancellation
receives 34. proof have a good day
yes
we'll get a good hack okay I'd say
that's right off our left wing now so
we'll go ahead and get a good hat so
t-hat time the time I'm seeing here is
2301 so I'll add three minutes because
I'm behind three minutes that gives us a
total time of 26 minutes and one second
okay so we know that it's taken us 26
minutes and one second of total time to
get to our first Waypoint so if we want
to know how long it took us to fly this
leg all we need to do is subtract 2601
minus 10 minutes and 30 seconds
now we can see that it took us 15
minutes and 31 seconds to fly from our
top of climb to our first Waypoint now
if we'd been resetting our timer on
every Waypoint we wouldn't have had to
do any math here we'd simply fill in our
time here and reset the clock but if
you're using total time like I do you'll
have to do a little bit of math to get
this number all right so time we wrote
down our time
now we need to apply 2a2 I have a 2a2
heading set now altitude 24.
Bartlesville VOR and I'll dial that in
here
okay 2601 so we're behind
anytime our timing calculations are
behind the first thing we should be
thinking about is whether or not we have
enough fuel to get to our destination
but there are a few other basic
questions we might want to find the
answer to before we can do any of those
let's fill out our nav log the entire
purpose in this thing is to make it easy
to calculate all this stuff so think of
this as a tool that's going to help you
not something you have to accomplish
when you go fly
okay so we know that it took us 15
minutes and 31 seconds to go 11 miles
now let's pull out our flight computer
and I'll find 11 miles on this outer
ring then rotate the whiz wheel until
15.5 minutes on the inner scale lines up
with that
then I can read my ground speed across
from the rate triangle looks like our
ground speed was just over 42 knots good
grief we had a kicking headwind and now
that we know that we can answer just
about any questions we might need to
know
the first question I might want to know
is how long it's going to take me to get
there well if you look over here I wrote
down our distance remaining in red looks
like we have 73 miles left on this trip
now if I continue to fly the exact same
ground speed all the way to my
destination my flight computer is
already set up all I need to do is find
my distance remaining on the outer ring
of my Wiz wheel and look across from
that to see that it's going to take us
another 103 minutes to get to my
destination
that seems excessive doesn't it yeah it
is a little if you start making
calculations immediately after your top
of climb your numbers aren't going to be
very accurate because once you level off
you're going to be speeding up from your
climb speed to your crew speed and this
can mess up your calculations a little
bit but just to be safe I'm going to
check and see if we're going to have
enough fuel for this trip if we were to
stay at the same ground speed to do that
I'll grab my flight computer and spin in
7.1 gallons per hour under the ray Arrow
then I'll look for 103 minutes on the
inner ring then I simply look across
from that to see that we should burn
12.2 gallons the rest of the trip
up to this point it looks like I should
have burned 30.9 gallons of fuel so if I
subtract 12.2 from that it looks like
we're going to have about 18.7 gallons
of fuel left when we land and this is
going to be way more than the required
30 minutes of fuel reserves a 3.55
gallons
what if I want to know my time of
arrival that's easy all I need to do is
look down at my watch then do a little
bit of math if the current time is 7 44
all I need to do is add 103 minutes to
that 103 minutes is 1 hour and 43
minutes so I can just add that to 744 to
see that we should arrive at 9 27 a.m
point is going to be the Bartlesville
VOR and that looks like it's going to be
a one one seven point Niner the 117.99
that and active here and the one that
we're looking for is a 2-2 radial so
we'll go ahead and set two two in there
and as soon as we get a from indication
the needle is centered and we know we're
on that Waypoint we still want to use
on this one but it's not as important
it's the CDI is going to center right on
our
right on our Waypoint the difference
from the station so we might be left or
right of course it's impossible to know
without looking down at the ground zero
seven four six seven Kansas City Center
radio check
Kansas City Center good morning clear
director Arnett final maintain flight
level two three zero sure garnet and up
to two three zero 438.2
since the aircraft has one information
connected segment one zero Central
protects Oklahoma one four five five
available flight service frequencies
that uh
he's saying there's some weather we
wanted to get that we could listen to
the flight service frequencies to get
that okay so we've got a few minutes
before we get to our next Waypoint but
on the way I want to talk about what to
do if you get off course there's a bunch
of different techniques out there but
I'll show you one that I like to use
first you need to make sure that you
know exactly where you are on the map
and you can do that by pilotage or
whatever and once you know that you can
determine how far you are off course
using your plotter and once you know
that distance here's a little trick to
get you back on course without too much
work for every one nautical mile that
you're off course apply a 10 degree
course correction for 3 minutes and 30
seconds for example if I'm on this leg
and I'm one nautical mile to the right
of course I should fly 272 for 3 minutes
and 30 seconds then I'll simply go back
to my original heading of 282 now I want
to say this math is calculated at 100
knots ground speed so subtract a little
bit of time if your speed is faster for
instance if I was flying 120 knots
ground speed I would do this for three
minutes and see what that got me alright
so we're looking
for ground
at this Waypoint we
went and remember my timer is three
minutes ahead so I'm actually going to
be looking for 29 minutes
sure would have been nice to hack the
clock on takeoff then I wouldn't have to
do all this stupid math MAP we're
looking for the 2-2 radial off the
Bartlesville VOR then ground if you're
close enough you could see the VOR on
the ground and we actually saw it you
may not be able to see it in the video
though all right cdis are starting to
come alive here yeah 366 contacts
and then we'll do our t-hat once the
cdi's center
we'll go ahead and use this one it looks
a little bit more accurate so right
there the CDI Center we know we're on
our Waypoint so hack we got uh 40
minutes and 43 seconds I took off three
minutes
43 minutes
and 43 seconds 43 minutes
43 seconds
all right so we'll do our t-hat we got
our time heading heading is two a two
altitude we're staying at 4 500 and our
next turn point is going to be a field
off our right hand side called Trophy
Ridge
might not be the best Waypoint but
there's not a lot between here and our
destination so we'll see if we can see
it it's going to be off the right hand
side now let's make some calculations
and see if our ground speed is any
better on this leg or if that wind's
going to keep us at a grandma Pace the
whole way
okay so our total time was 43 minutes
and 43 seconds so we can subtract the
time at our last Waypoint from that
looks like that was 26 minutes and one
second
it looks like it took 17 minutes and 42
seconds to fly this leg and once again
if we wanted to restart the timer on
every leg we could just do that instead
and write that in here if we wanted
okay so it took us 17 minutes and 42
seconds to go 20 miles
so let's take out our flight computer
and now we can find 20 on the outer ring
and rotate 1742 over to that and it
looks like our ground speed is 68 knots
we've sped up a little but we're still
dealing with a pretty impressive
headwind alright so now how long is it
going to take us to get there well it
looks like we have 53 miles to go so
let's look back at 53 miles on our
flight computer and across from that I'm
seeing about 47 minutes so we can expect
the rest of this trip to take us 47
minutes let's go ahead and take a quick
look at our fuel situation again now
that we have a little bit better idea of
how long we have left I'll spin in 7.1
gallons then I'll look across from 47
minutes on the inner ring to see that we
should burn about 5.6 gallons the rest
of the way okay now that I know that my
time is way off because of these winds
should we still use these original fuel
calculations over here to see how much
fuel we should arrive with probably not
but all we really need to do is find out
how much longer we've been flying than
we expected well we were supposed to get
here at exactly 32 minutes and we
actually arrived at 43 minutes and 43
seconds so we've been flying 12 more
minutes than we expected so that tells
me that we burned 12 more minutes of
fuel than we expected too so let's look
back at the flight computer to find 12
minutes on the inner ring looks like we
burned 1.4 gallons more than we
anticipated not really a big deal today
so if we have 29.2 gallons of fuel on
board we can subtract 1.4 from that then
we can see that we're going to have 27.8
gallons left then if we need 5.6 for the
rest of the trip are we going to have
enough fuel to make it to our
destination and have the required fuel
reserves yep it looks like we're going
to land with 22.2 gallons and that's
more than enough to be safe and legal
okay
we're back on our heading here looks
like we're true
okay so they're there you ate my cop to
contact Oklahoma City approach one two
four point six today oh are they there
already yes yep taking us way longer
than we thought well the wind uh yeah
after Wing 13 20 say right condition
I'll use this at the weather yeah
[Music]
we're uh
44 nautical miles outside
yes 40 minutes yeah all right
precipitation 12 uh correction 11 to 12
o'clock 100 miles extensive about the
Ponca City area
actually I think I see the field right
there
maybe maybe not
all right so we're about a minute away
from our time so clock we're getting
close to our time
what should we see we should see a
private field up our right hand side
so we'll look at the ground now
Kansas City
this one's going to be a little bit
tougher to see like I said I picked this
Waypoint because there's not much out
here
at the Durango airport let's see what we
can see here in a minute now if you ever
fly over your Waypoint and you don't
ever see it it's really important that
you continue the flight just like you
would have if you did see it allow the
clock to continue if you're using total
time like I do and if you're restarting
your timer on every leg go ahead and
restart it at the appropriate time I
don't see it it's only 9008 80 feet long
so it's a short little
step out of 3100 direct to 80 say 47.
all right so actually I think I do see
it it's right there below us
doesn't look like it's used much okay so
time I got 55 43 so 56 57 58
43. okay
so 58 43 time heading uh we're still on
a 2-8 282
I should be 281 now
[Applause]
okay altitude we're still at 4 500 Turn
Point our next turn point is a road Bend
okay now all right let's go ahead and
write down our time of 58 minutes and 43
seconds then we'll solve some problems
using the 60 to 1 Rule and you're going
to see that this is actually quite a bit
faster than breaking out the flight
computer all right let's take 5843 and
subtract 4343 and we can see that it
took us 15 minutes to fly this leg then
all we need to do is take our distance
of 17 miles and divide that by 15
minutes to see that we're going about
1.13 nautical miles a minute if I wanted
to know my speed in nautical miles per
hour I could just multiply my nautical
miles a minute times 60 and this will
give me 68 nautical miles per hour oddly
enough that's the exact same speed we
calculated on the last leg as well now
if you're using the 60 to 1 rule I
recommend writing your nautical miles a
minute in the square instead of your
nautical miles per hour you're going to
find that a little bit more handy and
now if we want to find out how long it's
going to take to get to our destination
all we have to do is divider distance
remaining of 36 miles by our nautical
miles per minute so 36 miles divided by
1.13 equals
31.86 minutes now to find out how much
fuel we're going to be burning the rest
of the way first we need to find out how
many gallons of fuel we're going to be
burning per minute so let's take our 7.1
gallons per hour and divide that by 60.
we're going to be burning about 0.119
gallons per minute and if you notice I
figured this out before the flight and I
wrote it up here on the nav log that way
it's handy when I start making my
calculations okay so to figure out how
much fuel we're going to burn the rest
of the way all we have to do is take our
time remaining to our destination of
31.86 minutes and multiply that times
0.119 gallons per minute and when we
multiply those two together it looks
like we're going to be burning about 3.8
gallons the rest of the way
x-ray Center
three one four eight x-rays are about
that number three one four eight x-ray
change to my frequency one two seven
point eight
kids City Center three one point x-ray
up on 1278. throw on four decks for
other City reports
okay well we're driving to the next
Waypoint I want to talk about a couple
more things real quick what happens if
we get lost
so obviously you've got a lot of tools
available to you if you get lost but one
thing you can remember is the three C's
fine conserve confess if you climb up it
might be easier to spot waypoints that
you didn't see before especially Lakes
Lakes are some of the best waypoints to
try to find if you're lost
and then could uh climb conserved so by
climbing up and slowing down to Best
Glide speed or best endurance if your uh
poh just tells you the best endurance
that's going to get you the best uh fuel
burn uh for your engine and then confess
whoever you're on with whether that be
Kansas City Center or you can even talk
to flight service stations and tell them
you're lost just fess up confess and
then from there they can help you get a
vector or whatever but like I said you
know we've got all these GPS's vor's
these days so you shouldn't be getting
lost but if you were to happen if that
were to happen you can you can use a
three C's climb conserve confess okay so
something else that you might get asked
to do is to defer
what happens if you know the field
straight ahead of us is on fire or
something crazy is going on they close
the field for something
you need to know how to divert and the
first thing you need to do is plot a
course immediately and then immediately
head that way
modern GPS's like this one have lots of
tools available to you you can hit this
nearest button right here and then it'll
tell you what builds closes and then you
can just go direct enter and almost all
of them have that sequence of nearest
direct enter and you can go direct to
that field but whatever the case if you
just want to use the chart that you have
in front of you that's another option
too just plot the course and immediately
turn that direction get headed the right
direction and then you know solve
problems after that all right so another
feature you have available to you is on
almost all GPS's
you notice right here this dtk and then
we have a trk this dtk is your desired
tracks
that the airplane needs to fly in order
to get to your destination that's your
desired track and then over here we have
your track this is your actual track
that tells you uh it's not your heading
it's your track so if we want to get
back on that track in this case we'd
need to make a slight left turn to get
back on track and then as you can see it
coming over right there you can look
over and see what heading we're flying
and then from there
the uh 200 299
3500 and uh changes to my frequency
128.6 okay I'm ready my airplane
[Applause]
visibility one zero
Sky condition clear temperature one
Niner Celsius dew point one seven
Celsius altimeter two niner niner eight
enter the altitude 1900
[Applause]
field Arkansas City Kansas strotherfield
airport automated weather observation
one three two seven Zulu wind zero eight
zero at zero three visibility one zero
[Applause]
all right another six minutes or so and
uh
we should be able to look at her map
and then down at the ground to see if
we're close to our Waypoint
for 55 Roger box truck 98 shall show
oh you guys should get back pretty quick
though yeah
like twice as fast
see if I can see that playing about the
shoot right underneath us here
yeah he's running about 171 knots oh
he's underneath us yeah he's 2400 feet
below the tree when he starts to make
your decent I've got some uh traffic
just below you and ahead 2500 looks like
they are climbing it quite a bit faster
they should uh outrun you uh Roger we
got
it okay so we're getting close to our
time so we got clocked to map to ground
so time closer in time
we should be crossing a road Bend and
we're crossing on the right side of this
road uh so now I start looking outside I
see the Road Bend in fact there's a
little Bridge right there I don't I know
the chart does not depict a bridge but
um there's actually a pond there so I do
see that yeah
we're definitely about to cross our
Waypoint and we'll get a really good
hack on this and we'll do one more
computation
all right let's go ahead and pack the
clock
so I'm showing 70 November 776 November
golf you've got the frequency and air
contact game City Center one two zero
points
it's going 78 minutes exactly all right
78 minutes exactly
so that took us 19 minutes
again seven seconds all right 19 minutes
and seven seconds so let's go ahead and
do some quick calculations and then
we'll head down to the field okay so we
went 25 miles and it took us 19 minutes
and seven seconds let's call that 19.1
minutes to make things easy on ourselves
let's take our distance of 25 and divide
that by 19.1 to see that we're traveling
1.3 nautical miles a minute now that's
our ground speed so I'll write it in
here and honestly I don't even care
about my nautical miles per hour I don't
need to know that for any reason now if
I want to know how long it's going to
take me to get to our destination all I
have to do is take our distance
remaining of 11 miles and divide that by
1.3 nautical miles a minute looks like
it's going to take us 8.46 more minutes
and if I wanted to know how much fuel
we're going to burn in between here and
there I could just multiply that by our
0.119 gallons per minute that I wrote up
here in the corner
looks like we're gonna burn just barely
over one gallon between here and our
destination as you can see once you get
the 60 to 1 roll figured out this is
definitely the way to go if you want to
be super precise fast and not have to
Lug around a flight computer but it does
take a little bit more practice in the
beginning anyway our top of descent is
our last Waypoint today and it's five
miles from the field I calculated that
at 500 feet per minute so I can hit my
pattern altitude exactly one mile from
the field it's kind of amazing how much
you can accomplish with just a little
bit of math I've got six miles
City Center good morning
December 3148x race further airports 12
o'clock seven miles to Fort field inside
it's
3140 x-ray Runner I'd have to pick no
traffic between you and the field to
walk the farm for exchange approved
if our change approved thanks for the
help today we're going forward x-ray
November 42525
all right so we're going to start our
descent at six miles because that's what
I have plans uh we'll see how well this
works out there it is
[Applause]
we'll just set 500 feet per minute on
The Descent see what that gets us so
pattern altitude should be 2 000.
all right so 2 000 on the pattern now
because this video took way longer than
expected all my GoPro batteries died at
the same time so to make this video
aesthetically pleasing I leave you with
my landing footage from the other day
but here are two words of wisdom you can
take with you on your next cross-country
flight first don't forget to hack your
clock on takeoff and also make sure you
get the most current wind out of you can
before you go fly my calculations were
off by nearly 17 minutes today because I
got the wins 12 hours in advance and I
wasn't expecting a headwind nearly this
strong anyway I hope you learned
something today if you did please hit
that like button for me and see what
other videos I have available in my next
Private Pilot ground lesson I'm going to
teach you everything you need to know
about weight and balance and when that
video is finished I'll put it right here
thanks for watching see ya approach
you're not gonna believe this I just
bought a free pilot training I'm going
to keep on watching